welcome back to new rock stars I'm G EPO
and this is a breakdown of wild blue
yonder the second of three Doctor Who
specials celebrating the show's 60th
anniversary this Russell T Davis Penn
episode picks up right after the events
of the star beast and features a little
bit of body horror and spooky Vibes in
the vein of some past favorites Eric is
on paternity leave and as the resident
Doctor Who nerded new rock stars I'm
filling in on these next two Who
episodes so let's break this down for
all the Easter eggs references and
deeper layers of meaning that you might
have missed we open in England in 1666
just as Isaac Newton exits his house to
go sit under an apple tree he's played
by Nathaniel Curtis best known for
playing Ash in the Russell T Davis
series it's a sin an apple falls on
Newton's head and just as he's about to
have his Epiphany the Tardis crashes
into the apple tree upon learning the
year the doctor tells Newton to stay
away from London he's warning him about
the Great Fire of London which ravaged
the city that same year we saw in the
fourth doctor episode the visitation
that the doctor was actually responsible
for starting the fire 14 accidentally
spoils that Newton will be kned calling
him sir and then telling him not yet
spoilers this was a repeated word of
River Song who said it to the doctor on
multiple occasions including right
before her death in forest of the Dead
Newton was born in 1643 so he's 23 here
he won't be kned by Queen an until 1705
at the age of 62 so it's still a ways
off just like she was when she met
Agatha Christie Don is absolutely
delighted to meet him and can't resist
making a pun you can
appreciate the gravity of the situation
they fly off and Newton misremembers the
word as mavity which has Ripple effects
that we see throughout the episode in
the pirate Planet the fourth doctor
claimed to have given Newton the idea
for Gravity by dropping an apple on his
head and then properly explaining it to
him over dinner that episode was
actually written by Hitchhiker's Guide
to the Galaxy author Douglas Adams and I
think we see some Adams inspiration
later on we cut to the opening credits
this episode was directed by Tom
Kingsley best known for directing
episodes of the show ghosts the original
English version not the American one on
CBS kingy was super excited about
working on Doctor Who and set on x/
Twitter that he was watching with his
dad who watched the live broadcast of
the first ever episode when he was 11
years old I just think it's so cool how
much everyone who works on this show
seems to love working on this show the
TARDIS is heavily damaged and belting
out the US Air Force song crash lands in
an unknown spaceship this song is where
we get the title of the episode off we
go into the wild blue yonder climbing
High into the sun I'm so sorry as the
doctor pokes his head inside to assess
the damage we hear the cloer bell ring
and again this is never a good thing in
logopolis the fourth doctor told adric
that the Ring of the cloer Bell signaled
wild catastrophes and a sudden calls to
man The Battle Stations the doctor says
that the Tardis can regenerate itself
we've seen this in episodes like the
11th hour and the po Monument but in
those instances the doctor triggered the
Regeneration so this might be the first
time we hear that it can happen
automatically in the past the Tardis
changing Interiors was referred to as
basically the same process as changing a
desktop background so that's lesser
regeneration more like a makeover after
he sticks the Sonic in the keyhole the
doctor says it can rebuild maybe a play
on we can rebuild him from the $6
Million Man Donna mentions her
grandfather setting up his return at the
end of this episode in true Wilfred form
he didn't like his little granddaughter
singing the US Air Force song in primary
school since it sounded jaunty and fun
but was actually about the military
going to war Donna says could be worse
we've got air we've got lights we've got
mavy the doctor knows that mavity isn't
the right word and that their
interaction with Newton altered
something but he keeps mum I mean
they've got other stuff to worry about
right now the interior of the ship has
hexagonal patterns on the walls and
floor a really common design Trope in
sci-fi apparently hexagons are used in
some NASA creations and are very
efficient and sturdy Donna asks if it
was just her or if Isaac Newton was hot
and 14 responds he was wasn't he he was
so hot
oh is that who I am now the doctor is
still feeling out who this iteration is
last episode he said he absolutely loved
Donna and then said do I say things like
that now he seems to be more open with
his feelings and by the way if Captain
Jack Harkness heard him say what he just
did he would absolutely die with joy the
Tardis takes off without them with the
Sonic still in the keyhole and Donna
gives a very Tenth Doctor what the
doctor has been separated from the
Tardis before in Voyage of the Damned it
flow floated away and landed back on
Earth while he was still on the Titanic
in fires of Pompei it gets sold to
cisilia and that's just to name a couple
examples he explains the hads Hostile
action displacement system to Donna
which we've seen before in the 11th
doctor episode Cold War and in many
comics and books we've also seen the
Tardis run away from danger like in
Utopia when it went to the end of the
universe to try and shake off Jack
Harkness who was clinging to the outside
a voice on the ship's intercom States
Fen law and the interior rearranges
itself with the Tardis gone and its
translation Matrix with it nothing is
being translated as they get into the
orange cart the doctor says your car my
lady and she responds thank you Paca a
reference to Lady Penelope and her
driver Parker from the 60s Sci-Fi series
Thunderbirds which used Marinette
puppets they meet the slow-moving robot
that Donna dubs Jimbo whose design
reminds me of Marvin the Paranoid
Android from Hitchhiker's Guide also
kind of looks like a more retro smile
robot that the doctor encountered before
Donna steals the doctor's catchphrase
and ribs him with it
Al as idiots say e them speeding along
having a good time in this cart reminded
me of the first time they met in the
Runaway Bride when they used Segways to
Traverse the tunnel leading under the
temps in the cockpit 14 discovers that
the ship fell through a wormhole and
what they're looking at is the nothing
at the end of creation which is why
there aren't any stars Donna says
my this Echoes the sentiment she
expressed when she was similarly
separated from her family in the stolen
Earth where she said that's my
family my whole world traveling with the
doctor often puts companions at risk of
never seeing their life once again 14
says he's never been this far out in the
flux he went outside the universe to the
space between universes and like I said
earlier in Utopia he went to the end of
the universe but there were still things
to be seen there and of course now I'm
thinking of the terrifying tane that the
master made out of the last of the human
race and I'm going to have nightmares
speaking of nightmares this is when 14
and Donna hear a metallic clanking noise
that they can't identify followed by the
word callus on the intercom and Jimbo
takes another step the doctor tries to
work out what the words mean saying like
a list or solicitors or a countdown or
instructions Donna guesses it might be a
warning and he responds slow warning
this whole part sort of foreshadows what
we find out in the end that it was in
fact a very slow Countdown the doctor
licks the base plate repetition
filaments something he used to do all
the time to figure out any number of
things like what planet he was on or if
something was dangerous the doctor and
Donna separate and then it gets cold
something that happens in horror movies
when there are ghosts or demons around
so you know some is about to go
down this is 20 minutes into the episode
and we're only now being introduced to
the big bad and I just love that the
whole thing is like slow played thank
you to geology for partnering with us to
bring you this video and also for giving
our audiences exclusive access to their
new try Before You by program you've
probably heard me mention geology before
the 28 time award-winning skin hair and
body care company recognized in men's
health hype Beast bird Esquire askmen
and Oprah daily grooming Awards but hey
I get it it can be tough to change a
skincare routine or start a new one part
of what's nice about gy is they create
simple and effective skincare and Hair
Care routines customized just for you
and now if you want to try that new
routine out before you buy a bunch of
stuff you can geology is offering new
rockstars viewers a free trial of their
eight piece skincare set with their try
before you buy a program you can
experience a new skincare routine
risk-free for 14 days if you don't love
it send it back it's that easy the set
is valued at $139 all you pay today is
the price of shipping and if you order
today get a free vitamin C plus e fuic
acid as a gift you don't need to return
it that's yours just head to geology.com
neww rockstars and get your free trial
and geology will send you a personalized
skincare routine and if you don't mind
me I'm going to take some geology and uh
uh look good for the rest of this video
Donna talks to who she thinks is the
doctor about how long her family will
wait for her in the alley to come back
and while she's giving this heartfelt
monologue the real doctor in the other
room also gets cold and who he thinks is
Donna walks in our first indication that
something is terribly wrong Donna says
that her grandfather would install
himself with a sleeping bag and a
thermus and he would sit there forever
waiting for her this is a bit of
foreshadowing for him being right there
at the end of the episode we saw Wilfred
and partners in crime sitting up the
hill and stargazing looking for aliens
Donna visited him up there and brought
him a thermos the doctor has an equally
heartfelt and absolutely wonderful
monologue about his Tardis enduring the
rise and fall of civilizations around it
it's been the only real constant in his
life and the story mirrors a lot of his
friendships with companions they often
start off Rocky at least in the first
episode where most companions don't know
who he is yet then they blossom until
eventually something happens and the
companion leaves or he leaves them and
then he's left all alone only for the
cycle to repeat itself when asked if he
misses home galif Fray 14 responds that
it got complicated okay so the Spy
Master killed the last remaining time
Lords on galifrey during the Timeless
child and a death particle destroyed all
remaining life on the planet there may
be a few time Lords out there in the
wild still but for now galif FR is
basically a dead Planet so yeah I'd say
that's complicated and then we get this
terrifying moment my arm's too
long and in the vein of episodes like
midnight blink and the empty child this
episode takes a turn to straight up
horror David Tenant and Katherine Tate
each get to play two roles and they
absolutely crush it these creepy long
arms each of them has are actually a
practical effect there's a great behind
the scenes video where you can see them
on set with these absurd looking
Prosthetics it is awesome 14 tries to
talk with the creatures did you come
from outside we came from the
nothing we are not things the not things
chase them down unable to maintain their
body size and shape the doctor works out
that they have their memories and
they've been turning heat into Mass to
create their bodies which is why it got
cold earlier the intercom says the word
braak and things rearrange separating
the doctor and Donna again and the Dutch
angle the flickering lights the echoing
noises all serve to disorient and
basically creep us out the doctor and
Donna reunite times too and now we don't
know who's real and who's a not thing
everyone tries to convince everyone else
that they're the genuine article and
then we get an exchange that's sure to
divide fans fake Donna tells the doctor
that he's not from galif Fray and he
doesn't know where he from this is a
reference to the Timeless child Arc from
13's run the doctor was originally the
Timeless child a mysterious being found
beneath a wormhole by a woman named te
tun the Timeless child could regenerate
its body in appearance and te tun
spliced this gene into her own creating
the time Lords it's unclear where the
doctor came from or what the doctor
really is a lot of fans thought that
Davis might retcon or possibly even
ignore this storyline from showrunner
Chris chibal but this makes it clear
that he's doing no such thing fake Donna
says that when she was the doctor Donna
she saw into 14's mind and saw
everything that happened in the 15 years
since he and Donna traveled together and
he is shook the doctor carrying a ton of
guilt about the flux that was the
universe-wide apocalypse that 14
confirms here wiped out half the
universe it was created by the division
which was led by teun as a means of
destroying this universe and the Doctor
Who had forgotten history as a division
agent that they were starting to
remember the flux was also meant to
catapult the division into a new
universe where they could once again
dictate events but it was hijacked by
the Swarm and te and was killed the flux
was eventually absorbed before it could
destroy the entirety of this universe
yes this show is Bonkers I love it this
emotional exchange gives the doctor hope
that he's talking to his best friend I
just love the emotion and vulnerability
in tenant's voice here it's something
very rarely seen from the doctor and he
Nails
it but then the rug gets ripped right
out from under him as he watches fake
Donna's legs melt into the ground in
front of him real Donna tricks fake
doctor into revealing himself and he
does the upside down spider walk that
was made famous by the exor but has
popped up in many horror movies since
then the real doctor has a very human
freak out tenant loves throwing a good
rager while playing the doctor I think
here he's mad that he let himself trust
fake Donna the doctor doesn't
traditionally talk about their feelings
much and this Incarnation did but here
it definitely bit him in the ass and I
think we'll see him close himself off a
little as a result all four doctors and
Donna reunite and these two acting
opposite themselves is brilliant they're
very clearly having fun with it with
tenant talking as fast as he can trying
to out Logic the other him and tap
complimenting how she looks with a wink
and a ey this trick the real doctor
pulls with assault is something that's
used in shows like Supernatural with
demons being unable to cross assault
line and in the xfiles episode Bad Blood
a vampire to stop and pick up and count
every spilled sunflower seed before he
could continue his attack real doctor
tells fake Donna stop copying and make
your own minds up cross the line one of
the most disturbing episodes from the
previous tenant and Tate era was
midnight when the doctor encounters a
creature who can possess people and
repeat everything that's said he was
left deeply unsettled by the whole
experience and by anyone copying him the
not things want to use the Tardis to
travel to earth and they're close to
becoming completely doctor and
completely Donna and if that happens the
Tardis won't be able to tell the
difference between them but the doctor
figures out that the more afraid they
are the more they think the easier it is
to copy them he says if we're slow they
can't read us and I'm going to liken
this to a sort of mental T-Rex but of
course 14 is incapable of not thinking
and he discovers that what's been making
that metallic clanging this whole time
is the dead Captain it's this sort of
Beta Ray Bill horse alien creature
creature banging against the outside of
the ship freaky after that he quickly
puts all the pieces together with a
Little Help from Donna the captain put a
very slow plan in motion and then killed
herself so the not things wouldn't
realize what she'd done the words on the
intercom are a very slow countdown Jim
the robot has been very slowly walking
down the hallway to set off a very slow
bomb but the action in the last 10
minutes of this episode is very fast
Donna and not Donna fight the not doctor
gives Chase on all fours like a creepy
bited wolf and the Tardis comes back
just in the nick of time there's this
terrifying moment where the doctor
brings the wrong Donna on board before
realizing his mistake and I like legit
thought this was going to be how Donna
goes out it's Doctor Who so you never
know I mean the 11th doctor traveled
with a fake ganger Amy Pond for a while
so the doctor asks Donna if she has
knowledge of what he's been through for
the past 15 years and he seems sad when
she says no but he also closes off and
won't share with her so no doubt that's
a result of being burned by trusting the
not thing Don and they land back in
Camden Market where they originally left
off and just like she thought he'd be
Wilfred is waiting for her Bernard CRI
been back in his last role before his
passing I got to admit this whole end
part had me tearing up his whole
performance here is so incredible when
he sees the doctor the doctor with his
old face the face that saved his life
sacrificed his life for him just oh the
see you again after all these years
honestly this is a sentiment that
probably applies to cribbons as well he
probably genuinely felt this I mean to
come back to Doctor Who three times in
his life as two different characters his
Emotion and Joy just seems so genuine
and Wilfred tips them off that some
something isn't right with this world
right before all hell breaks loose in
the street and a plane crashes Davis
loves his crashes the end of the episode
says in loving memory of Bernard
cribbons 1928 to 2022 he didn't live to
see these episodes air but what a legacy
there's one more episode in the 60th
specials the giggle coming December 9th
which features the return of the
celestial toy maker an old foe from
classic Doctor Who so when I did my
classic who watch a few years back three
of the four episodes of the original
Celestial toy maker Arc were missing but
I watched the fourth one I was confused
although I managed to fill it out with
the Tardis Wiki explanation so I'm very
excited to see this one with Neil
Patrick Harris stepping into the role
let us know in the comments what you
thought about this episode and if you're
excited for the next one thank you to
the awesome Noah Chen for helping
research and write this episode follow
me on Instagram and Twitter at Gina ippy
follow new rockstars subscribe to new
rock stars thanks for watching
bye